en el vídeo anterior vimos como todo el
mundo en el país quería invertir en el
país ves estaban súper emocionados y
quería convertir su tipo de moneda al
tipo de moneda manejado en el país ve y
con esta nueva demanda de la moneda
deben harían que la moneda debe fuera
más elevado su precio pero en lugar de
dejar que esto pasará el banco central
del país me dijo no no no no no espera
un momento yo quiero mantener las tasas
de intercambio estables entonces lo que
voy a hacer es imprimir veces y los
usaré para comprar a y qué pasó al final
a bueno lo que sucedió porque el banco
central del país ve terminó con reservas
de moneda extranjera del país a en su
hoja de balance ahora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es pensar qué sucede
si la demanda va en el sentido opuesto y
cómo le puede hacer el banco central
para usar sus reservas de divisa
extranjera y así prevenir que su moneda
sufra una devaluación entonces vayamos a
la siguiente fase nuestra pequeña
historia hipotética todos los días
estaban súper emocionados con invertir
en el país 20 pero luego desde el país a
supongamos que se empieza a formar una
burbuja económica de algún tipo y los
inversionistas empiezan a sentir un poco
de miedo porque empiezan a escuchar
reportes de la burbuja formándose
entonces se dan cuenta que las
condiciones en el país ven no eran tan
buenas como ellos pensaban y entran en
pánico total ahora ellos quieren
revertir sus inversiones entonces lo que
ellos tenían en el país ve ahora quieren
venderlo y obtener monedas manejada en b
y luego convertirla a moneda de app así
que ahora tenemos la situación contraria
a lo que teníamos en el vídeo pasado
todos quieren vender sus vez entonces
invirtieron en el país ven y quizás
compraron bienes raíces debe las van a
vender y obtener vez por ellas luego
convertirán esta vez en as esta es la
situación contraria ahora todos quieren
salir del país vez y no hay mucha oferta
de los hacen retorno nadie realmente
quiere buscar el intercambio de veces
por haz ya que el mercado está
completamente manejándose en dirección
contraria y una vez más si los mercados
de divisas extranjeras si se les
permitiera afrontar libremente qué
pasaría
bueno pues en esta situación toda la
demanda está para los/as y toda la
oferta está para los ves así que
tendríamos una de dos uno de los dos
casos sería menos as por cada vez ese es
un caso y el otro caso
menos as por cada vez y otro caso sería
más ves más veces por cada us lo pongo
en verde más veces por cada a pero
digamos que nuevamente tú eres el
banquero central y ves lo que está
pasando y dice está ahora ya hay esta
situación tampoco me agrada ahora cuando
intentan desenrollar todo este revuelto
que siempre pasa que entran en pánico
aún más pánico esto causa más pánico que
la fase anterior la inicial esta de aquí
y dicen oh cielos la economía de nuestro
país corre peligro ahora sí esto podrá
pasar las importaciones por anne us se
volverían más caras tal que la gente
quizás no pueda comprar ni comida de
otros países o siquiera suministros
esenciales
y dice no vamos a intervenir acumulamos
algunas de las reservas de divisa
extranjera y las vamos a utilizar para
intentar estabilizar nuestra moneda así
que en esta situación lo que haría el
banco central el banco central diría
bueno yo tengo algunas de las reservas
de a iré al mercado abierto y voy a
vender estas reservas de la que tengo de
esta manera voy a intentar estabilizar
la oferta y la demanda y una vez más si
son capaces de vender todas las reservas
que tienen de a entonces así de pronto
su moneda no se va a devaluar o quizás
no tanto ahora aquí el problema en el
sistema es que solo tienen una cantidad
finita de reservas esto de aquí esto es
finito ahora recordemos en el vídeo
previo vimos que estaban imprimiendo su
propia moneda para construir reservas
ellos pueden hacer eso toda la noche
porque ellos tienen el derecho de
hacerlo imprimir cuánta moneda ellos
quieran pero ahora están usando esas
reservas de la moneda de otro país para
que su moneda no se devalúe ahora ellos
no pueden imprimir moneda de otro país
ellos
con la esperanza de que lo que tengan en
mano sea suficiente lo que ellos quizás
quieren es un desequilibrio a corto
plazo pero puede ser de miedo super
escalofriante qué sucede si toda esa
reserva se termina entonces sus reservas
de moneda extranjera
se esfuman y si ese pánico sigue en pie
entonces ellos tendrán que regresar a
las fuerzas del mercado libre y su
moneda se tendrá que evaluar y así es
como los bancos pelean así es como ellos
intentan mantener su moneda
relativamente estable en los vídeos
futuros veremos casos reales de esto web
y veremos cuando los reservas de divisas
extranjeras terminan y que más que nos
veremos a bueno también vamos a ver como
especuladores pueden usar este
conocimiento para ver cómo pueden hacer
dinero fácil